françois chauve ancien général de
brigade expert en géostratégie estime
lui qu emmanuel macron de se poser en
médiateur
on est quand même aussi représentant de
la france mais aussi de l'union
européenne a directement on est un
élément intermédiaires comme ça a été
dans la tradition français de
rapprochement comme troisième voie comme
de gaulle l'a fait entre la russie et
les etats unis par exemple donc
effectivement maintenant que fait le
méme annales mâcon il est aussi dans une
situation si je peux me permettre un peu
politique intérieure il est sur le
devant de la scène il est là aussi dans
le cadre des élections il doit se
montrer comme un médiateur donc
maintenant quels sont les rapports
personnels avec l'adie mur poutine il
est certain qu'on voit bien que et
benjamin cros et un homme chaleureux il
aime les relations humaines il fait je
pense ce qu'il peut pour se rapprocher
de vladimir poutine en termes de
relationnel mais maintenant il ya des
intérêts géopolitiques et il n'est pas
certain qu'aujourd'hui les intérêts
géopolitiques puisse entrer en ligne de
compte dans ses relations personnelles
donc c'est bien dehors des sourires
c'est bien de passer la main dans le dos
je ne suis pas certain que les résultats
soient résultats et des attentes
géopolitiques notamment d'al hima
poutine